all right everybody welcome my talk
es2016 the evolution of JavaScript first
a little bit about me my name is Jeffrey
Sain I'm a tech lead at Netflix I'm the
architect of Falkor which is an upcoming
UI data platform which we plan to
Netflix plans to release open source
pretty soon I got about six years of
experience writing reactive systems and
I was talking a little bit about that
later
and I'm also Netflix is one of that
flicks as representatives on the tc39
which is the JavaScript Standards
Committee so this talk actually used to
be called es 7 the evolution of
JavaScript but something happened a
couple of committee meetings ago we
decided to change the name of es6 to es
2015 and es 7 to es 2016 now there's a
little bit of controversy about this but
I want to explain this name change the
idea is that we as a committee want to
start shipping JavaScript every year we
want to move to a feature train model so
just the way you would ship software in
an agile way we want to be able to add
new features and ship them quickly and
so that's part of why we have this
rename so what you formerly knew is the
language formerly known as es6 is now
known as yes 2015 and the upcoming
language version is known as es 2016 so
yes 2016 features are already starting
to roll in the browser's and so for
example there's object.observe in chrome
right now and it's important to know
that yes 2015 and es 2016 were developed
concurrently so although there was this
big you know many many years between es
5 and es 2015 what the committee is
doing is they're developing new features
in the latest version of the language at
the same time as the developing features
in the next version of language and
that's exciting because it actually
helps us plan about the future of
JavaScript we don't have to do
everything in one release we can add
features today to es 2015 and we can
build on them right with the hopes of
building on them later in ES 2016 and so
the real question I want to talk - I
think the big story about it yes 2016 is
how do we make async programming easier
I think it's probably some folks out
there who who think this is kind of a
hard problem right and any pain out
there about async programming
yeah quite a few people I'm guessing so
starting with es5 we introduced
something to make
like just a little bit easier which is
arrow functions I'm not going to dwell
on this too long but as of es6 or yes
2015 I guess you'll now be able to
rewrite this this way I think most
people in this room are familiar with
arrow functions by this point you can
sort of get rid of the boilerplate I'm
not going to spend too long on this this
definitely helps out when you've got a
lot of callbacks in your code and you're
doing async programming error functions
are improvement but can we do better
what if you could write async programs
without any callbacks at all
how does that sound right yeah so we all
know that blocking is easy right
blockings no problem weak blocking let's
imagine for a moment this function which
gets a stock price calls get stock
symbol which makes a blocking xhr
requests one of those things sui
developers are never supposed to do
we're never supposed to make a blocking
xhr request right but it sure is easy
because then we can just wait for that
request to come back and block until it
does and then go ahead and pass the name
of the symbol for that stock and get the
price for it so we know that blocking is
easy but it produces a terrible user
experience because the you know our user
might be sitting there and our UI is not
responding to mouse clicks while we're
sort of going off and making that async
request so that's the type of thing
you're not supposed to do in JavaScript
now from now on when I say that we're
blocking what I want you to think is
pulling what what we're really doing
when we call a function and we receive
the output in the return position that
function and we're sort of blocking and
waiting so we're kind of like pulling
the value out of that function to the
left hand side we're pulling the value
out so when I say blocking I mean
pulling and what that means is data is
delivered in the return position of the
function that's how those functions are
in JavaScript most functions return
their data in the return position but
what if we decide that we want to wait
instead of block we don't want to block
the UI waiting for the output and not
being able to respond to user input we
want to be able to just wait well in
order to wait in JavaScript waiting
means pushing what it means is you hand
a callback to that function and that
function pushes the value the result of
that function in the argument position
of your callback so here's a typical
type of thing that you would see a node
write your hand a function a call back
and it pushes the value the result in
the
in position so as soon as we try to do
that as soon as we try to wait in
JavaScript we very rapidly find
ourselves in the pyramid of Doom if
you've done a lot of nodejs programming
you probably know what I mean
your code takes on this pyramid like
structure that you see there on the left
hand side so I'm gonna left on the left
hand side here with get stock price
we're doing a blocking function and
we're just the same function you saw
earlier but as soon as we want to move
to waiting on the right-hand side take a
look at how much more complicated our
function becomes why is there so much
more code here well for one thing it's
because we're doing the job the
JavaScript usually does for us if an
error is encountered anywhere in this
function right now as soon as we're
using callbacks to forward on those
errors we're responsible for making sure
that those errors get forwarded up
whereas when we're doing blocking code
we have try-catch to rely on so as soon
as the problem really what's going on
here is that since javascript doesn't
expect functions to wait they in
JavaScript
they sort of expects functions to block
well there's no support for reporting
errors this way and the language can't
provide you with any sort of support
whether it's loops or try-catch so
you're kind of on your own
but what if waiting we're just as easy
as blocking what if javascript
understood this concept of functions
that waited and it could provide you
syntactical support just like try-catch
and just and you could use loops for
example to repeat asynchronous functions
well in es2015 we got a little closer to
this vision with promises right now but
the way I think most of you probably
familiar out there with promises but I
think most people have been exposed to
them at this point but the way to think
about a promise is that it's an object
that represents the eventual value from
an asynchronous operation and so if you
want to get the value out of a promise
you call then and you pass in two
callbacks one is for receiving data if
the asynchronous offer operation
succeeded so that's the one on the left
hand side there and the other callback
is for receiving the air if that
asynchronous operation failed and so
it's sort of like a promise is like a
present did you unwrap and great if
everything worked out you get a value
but if things go bad you can get an
error so now let's take let's look at
that same previous example waiting with
callbacks and that pyramid of doom
structure that you see there and let's
see how we can now do the same thing
with promises so what's happened
here is promises actually take care they
catch any errors that occur and forward
them up until they are actually caught
where even pass an air handler notice
there and get stock price we pass an air
handler we don't have to catch airs
every possible step in the function we
just catch errors in one place and the
promise type will catch the errors and
forward it up until it's that there's a
function provided to handle that error
so what's actually happening is the type
is doing the job that try-catch does for
you in the language and so that's how we
got down back down to that nice little
piece of code so that's quite an
improvement
no more pyramid of doom it's not bad but
why can't we just write code that looks
pretty much the same regardless of
whether it's waiting or blocking right
what if we could just write our
algorithm and then make it really easy
to switch that algorithm between waiting
and blocking that promise code you saw
on the previous slide still looks pretty
long different than the synchronous
blocking code that you saw earlier well
as of es2015
you will now be able to wait like this
so using generator functions and the
yield keyword which is something I'm
going to tell you about later you can
actually write code that looks pretty
much exactly like the blocking code but
instead Waits
it doesn't walk and so you can allow
handling of user input but you can write
your code top to bottom furthermore you
can even take advantage just like in
blocking code of looping constructs to
now control flow in an asynchronous
program so now here over on the the
right-hand side I can use loops and I
can even use try-catch so how does this
work how do we make this work in
JavaScript well in order to explain that
to you I'm gonna have to explain
generators but I think the meta point
that I don't want you guys to understand
here is that pulling and pushing are
asynchronous excuse me are symmetrical
you can do the exact same thing you
write your code precisely the same way
whether it's pulling or pushing it's
kind of a detail you should just be able
to write your logic and then after the
fact decide whether you want that
function to push or you want it to be a
pulling function anything that you can
push you can pull out of a function I'm
going to demonstrate that in just a
moment
so in order to understand how that works
I'm gonna explain to you the most
powerful and most misunderstood feature
in es2015 and that is general
functions hands up quick how many people
have heard of generator functions okay
great
quite a few people how many people
understand them right okay so that's
hopefully what I want to rectify today
if I get well you get one thing out of
this talk it'll at least have a slightly
better understanding of what generator
functions are because I said they're
really powerful so here's at a high
level this is how I want you to think
about generator functions it's a
function that can return multiple values
well you can already make a function
that returns multiple values right you
throw a few values in an array and then
you return that well generator functions
can allow you to do that a little bit
more efficiently in some cases so this
is what a generator function looks like
in es2015 and for now the mental model I
want you to use to understand this yield
keyword is that sort of like an
intermediary return it's like a return
statement but it just sort of you know
runs in the middle and you can return
more values so if you're consuming the
data from a generator function this is
what it looks like in order to get the
data out you request an iterator by
calling that function what comes out is
an iterator an iterator is something
that you can call next on and then what
happens is the function evaluates to the
first yield and then stops and returns
that value and then it pops out of this
little tuple which contains the value
that was returned and a boolean telling
you whether or not there are more values
so if done is false we know that we can
call next again and I want you to look
on the left hand side execution is going
to resume and move to the next yield and
then pause and then return you another
tuple saying that value we know that we
still have more to do so I'm going to
keep calling yield our next excuse me
until finally gets returned and then we
get our last value and we know we're
done because done is true now that we
don't have all this magic right if I
wrote if I wanted you to write a get
numbers function today and es5
that did this you'd probably roll a
state machine right something that just
keeps track of where you are and every
single time I call next I get the next
value and so to see how that works let's
take a look at this Fibonacci sequence
function right here and I'm going to
show you what addy Sugar's two from
es2015 the es5 so what's going on is you
can see I've got the state variable on
the left-hand side and that's keeping
track of where
I am and notice I'm returning this
object with the next method that's the
iterator that you saw earlier
now as suit what the what this function
actually is doing is you as you can see
here what generator functions do is they
figure out every possible state that
that function can be in and they build a
state machine and so basically this get
the Bonacci sequence can be in three
different states when you call next it
can be in the state where it's supposed
to return zero at the very beginning the
state where it's supposed to return one
and then finally the state where it's
you're supposed to take whatever it
returned last time and whatever returned
the time before that add them together
and then return it in JavaScript in
es2015 this generator function is
actually smart enough to figure that out
and build this state machine for you and
what it's really doing is it's turning
what looks like a push
notice on me letting our on the on the
left hand side here yield kind of looks
like a push it's imagine yield was a
call back right and there was brackets
around that yield the code looks like
we're pushing the data but the compiler
turns it into code that poles by
building a state machine on the left
hand side so that's effectively what
generator functions do they let you
write code that looks like you're
pushing information when in fact it
turns it inside out and then it uses
pull for the control flow so for each
one of these yields we have that little
return which returns the tuple the value
and the done and it increments this
state variable as it goes along and then
that's how we move through the states so
this allows us to use a pattern called
iteration this whole process of getting
an iterator and pulling a value out of
it and pulling a value at it until
you're done is called iteration an
iteration involves a consumer and a
producer and the layer works is a
consumer requests an iterator from the
producer and then it pulls the value out
by calling next so the producer emits a
value right and why do I say it's pull
well notice I'm getting the value out in
the return position of next so I'm
pulling functions out I'm pulling values
out so I keep pulling values out until
finally I pull out a value and the
producer says you're done so that's how
it works you keep pulling values out
until the producer says I'm done no more
data so if generator functions return
iterators why are they called generator
from
why don't we just call them iterator
functions well there's more than meets
the eye
when it comes to generator functions a
generator is actually built out of two
different interfaces so the iterator
which you guys saw earlier where you can
call next and get out that little tuple
saying whether you have what the value
isn't whether you're done but it also
has an entirely other side it's like got
a split personality which is an observer
interface which gets pushed values so a
generator is both a source of data which
you can pull data out of but it's also a
sync which you can push data into so
these two interfaces combined create a
generator so a generator is an iterator
so you can pull a value out if you
attempt to pull it out a value out you
can get an error right because it might
throw when you call next and finally you
can pull a value out and get that done :
true in that little tuple so there's
really three types of notifications then
a producer can tell you during iteration
I've got some data an error occurred and
here's your final value well you can see
all of those notifications in Reverse on
the observer side so when you call next
on a generator you can also push a value
in by passing a value in the argument
position of next you can also send an
error in by calling throw and finally
you can send in a final value by calling
return so why does it observer have this
sort of split personality of both being
a source of data and sync well it's to
solve a little problem and that's that
iteration only allows data to flow in
one direction whereas with generators
two functions can effectively have a
conversation have a long-running
conversation I pull a value out I push a
value back in I pull a value out I push
a value back in why would I want to do
that what does that buy me well it
allows us to use a very powerful pattern
that I think a lot of the people in this
room are going to be using in the next
few years called asynchronous iteration
so here we have our generator function
and the first thing I want you to notice
about this generator function is that I
told you to use a mental model for
understanding yield the mental model I
gave you was it's sort of like an
intermediary return right but in this
particular piece of code yield seems to
be used like an expression right we're
assigning to the result of a you
so what's that about well here we have a
producer function and what it's actually
going to produce if you notice what's on
the right-hand side of those yields it's
going to be an iterator of promises so
we're going to pull promises out of this
iterator and then what we're going to do
is we're going to resolve those promises
and then push the value back in and so
we need a consumer to go along with this
producer the consumers job is just going
to be the pull out by calling next pull
out promises resolve those promises and
then push the value back in and what
you're going to see later is that when
you push a value back into the generator
that whole yield expression gets
replaced with the value that you put
back in and this is the key this is the
recipe to allow you guys to write code
that looks that looks like it blocks but
actually waits so let's take a look at
how this works we have this spawn
function which I'm going to define just
a moment but think of that is the
consumer it's pulling promises out of
this iterator of promise so if I run
this what spawn is going to do is it's
going to produce a promise which will be
the eventual result of get stock price
after we've resolved the get stock
symbol promise and the get symbol price
promise and so when I run this piece of
code eventually it's going to yield the
price of an individual stock in this
case Pfizer stop so how does this all
work well asynchronous iteration works
this way the same as iteration you got a
consumer and you got a producer the
consumer requests a generator from the
producer and then calls next pulls out
the first value but notice execution
suspends at the first yield and what
we're yielding back is a promise it's a
promise that will eventually resolve to
the symbol for sizer and so that promise
is handed to the consumer and the
consumer and the producer have an
agreement the consumer says every
promise I pull out I'm going to resolve
and then I'm going to push the value
back into the producer so the consumer
calls then on the promise waits until
it's resolved and then calls next again
on the generator from the producer
except this time notice we pass PF e in
the argument position of next we're
effectively pushing a value in at the
same time as we're pulling a value out
so we send PFE back in and now I want
you to look at what happens to the yield
expression
it effectively gets replaced with the
value that we get pushed in and then
execution resumes and pauses at the next
yield so now the consumers push in a
value and at the same time they're
pulling out another promise this time
for the price of that particular stock
so agreement between the consumer and
the producer the consumer is going to
resolve that promise and when it gets a
value it's going to call next again and
this time push 2783 back into the
producer that replaces yield and we
continue and stop at the final return
value so now we've actually returned
it's not a promise it's just a plain old
value back to the consumer and we said
hey we're done we're not going to give
you any more data at this point the
consumer takes that promise that it
returned the spawn function and it
resolves it to the final value 2783 so
pictures are great but let's take a look
at some code so here I have get stock
price and then I have this spawn
function which consumes it so notice hit
the bottom I'm calling spawn but I'm
passing in the generator that comes out
of get stock price into spawn and what's
going to come out of that is a promise
that it's eventually going to resolve to
the final price of that stock so I run
this and what happens is we immediately
create a promise inside of the spawn
function and we execution runs to the
very bottom and it hits this on result
function and this on result function is
just basically my way of asynchronously
looping and continuing to resolve
promises you're going to see me
recursively call this function again and
again every single time I get a new
value out of a promise so we just this
is the first time around so we go up
here we call generator next right the
last promise result is undefined I
haven't gotten any promises yet and so
as soon as I call next notice up there
at the top execution stops at the first
yield and we return a promise that sim
that symbolizes the eventual stock
symbol and that gets returned to the
consumer and if it's a promise the
consumer calls then on it notice how
here we're passing in the on result
function we started with except this
time when the on result function gets
called it's going to get the result of
that promise and so as soon as I do this
we're going to hop right back up here
and last promise result is going to be
whatever came out of that promise J and
J and so now I've got the result of the
promise is the producer but
want to push it back into the person to
the excuse me the consumer I want to
push it back into the producer so I call
next I pass back in jnj is the argument
and if you look up at the top there
notice what happens that yield symbol
promise expression it gets replaced with
J and J and execution resumes and stops
at the next yield point and so gets
symbol price is a promise that
eventually resolve to the price that's
what comes out to the consumer another
promise we call then on it again pass in
on result that recursively gets called
with the result of the last promise
which this time is the price and so we
do it all over again we call next yield
gets replaced with that price and then
we continue on to the very end of the
generator function at which point it
comes out and says you know what done is
true we're not going to get any more
values the consumer takes that doesn't
need to resolve it's not a promise and
then resolves the promise the overall
promise that was returned from spawn to
that final value and that's how a
synchronous iteration works and that's
how you can write code at the top right
that looks like it walks but it actually
waits so there is this spawn function
it's actually define a library that you
can go and try which is called pass J s
so if you are using a transpiler that
allows you to use yield in your code or
you're actually using a browser that's
you know yes 2015 capable lucky you you
can do this today right you just go
ahead download the spawn function which
is in task J s so that's how
asynchronous iteration works and that's
how generate generators interact with
promises to produce this pretty
impressive code but I mean why should we
have to download a library to do this I
mean this is going to be such a common
pattern in JavaScript of wanting to do a
whole series of operations and just sort
of pause until the asynchronous bits are
done why do we need a library why can't
we have direct support in the JavaScript
language for this and that is our first
feature today from es 2016 and it's
async functions and now you guys know
everything you need to know about how
async functions work they are like sugar
over what you just saw this combination
of spawn and yield soon in the next
version of JavaScript you will be able
to write code like this on the left hand
side so for those who are familiar with
c-sharp this features in c-sharp as well
you don't have to worry about generator
or helper functions you can just put the
word async in front of any function and
then inside of there anytime you want to
pause until a promise has been resolved
you can throw in a weight in there so
that's what's coming and the next
version of JavaScript so we're getting
closer to this vision of symmetrical
support for blocking and waiting in
JavaScript right if I want to wait I
throw a nation confront that function I
throw a few awaits in there I'd if I
want a block I take it out now in order
to talk about any features in the next
version of JavaScript responsibly we
have to talk about the es feature
maturity stages so as we develop new
proposals in the JavaScript committee
what we want to be able to do is move
them through these maturity stages so we
have time to prove them out and so when
I tell you about a future upcoming in
JavaScript I'm going to tell you about
which stage it is in maturity so async
functions are in the draft stage so that
means that the committee expects the
feature to be developed and included in
the standard I think it's very very
likely that we're going to see async
functions in the next version of
JavaScript so you it's definitely
something you can play with today if
you're using babel or a transpiler like
tracer I believe you can play with this
right now if you want to so go ahead try
it out that's why it's there and
transpilers and give us your feedback so
you can try async functions in babel
actually this is the slides a little bit
old but if you want to try it in
regenerator as well I believe they're
now in the main branch sorry the slides
a little bit old I think babel is
probably the easiest way and the most
likely way by which most you're going to
try this feature so the awake keyword
makes it really easy to await one
asynchronous value what if you want to
wait on multiple values we await
multiple values all the time WebSockets
Dom events there are lots of streams of
information that are being pushed at us
and there's no real language support for
traversing those streams of information
now in es6 all collections became
iterable and what the iterable thing is
it's a contract the array if you walk up
to the array for example it means you
can ask that array for an iterator and
then gradually consume its items one at
a time by pulling them out so here's a
good example right I can take an array
and I can walk up I call this symbol dot
iterator method and then I can get out
an iterator and I can just keep looping
and calling next but that's kind of
annoying that's a lot of boilerplate
which is why in ES 2000
fifteen we introduced this new four of
loop for consuming any collection that
happens to implement the iterable
contract so there's a couple of new
collections coming and es6 as well like
maps and you can use this to consume
that data progressively so that's what
the new for of loop is for it just use
sugars to what you see on the left hand
side there now if we can wait for values
that we can pull out for streams of
values that we can pull out why can't we
wait for streams of values that are
being pushed at us why can't we have an
equal support like a loop for consuming
data that comes out of a WebSocket
or data that comes out of async IO for
example that's the logic behind the
proposed for on loop for the next
version of JavaScript so if you have a
four of why can't you have a four on so
in this particular example I'm creating
an async function and inside I'm
actually consuming the prices from a
WebSocket and the very first price
differential that's over a certain
threshold I'm going to resolve the
promise to and grab that particular diff
between the previous price and the next
price no callbacks required I'm just
looping over a stream of information
being pushed at me so this would be
great to do right now I can when I run
this resolves to a promise to gives you
the next price spike in this stream of
stock prices but there's a little
problem there's a reason why we can't
have nice things just yet right the
problem is that the web has no standard
observable interface we have iterable as
of es6 we have this iterable contract
you saw earlier
will you call symbol dot iterator but
today we actually have this
proliferation of different api's that
push us streams of data that push us
data in a callback in this sort of a
streamed way we get multiple values Dom
events WebSockets server-sent events
send interval nodes streams XML HTTP
requests all these things can actually
push you multiple values but they don't
implement one common interface so one
thing that's proposed for es2015 r16
excuse me is the observable contract so
here we have the iterable contract
introduced in es 2015 how are we going
to get the observable contract well it's
actually hidden inside of this type in
fact if we just swap the arguments and
the return type of the iterable what
pops out is an observable unobservable
accepts a generator and then uses the
push side of the generator and pushes
multiple values into it until it finally
calls return to signal that no more
values are coming if you think about an
iteration and observation are both about
the same things they're both about a
producer giving your consumer multiple
values the difference is in one
circumstance with Dom events the data is
being pushed to you but when you're
using an iterator to pull values out of
an array you're pulling values right in
iteration the consumers in control and
an observation the producers in the
control right the WebSocket decides when
it calls you so it's sort of like
they're iterating you right the
producers iterating you by calling your
callback so how does observation work
well we know consumer and producer in
the relationship here with an iteration
it's the exact same process but kind of
the inverse so here the producer instead
of the consumer requesting a generator
from the producer the producer has VIX
to the consumer hands a generator to the
producer and in this context just think
about a generator is like three
callbacks right it's got the next the
throw and the return callbacks so it's
just sort of like you're handing an API
three callbacks and expecting it to push
information to you by calling your
callbacks and so the producer produces a
value and calls the next method on your
generator the one you provided to it and
that's how it pushes 42 to you and then
produce another value and at its leisure
decides to push 39 to you until finally
it says you know what there's no more
data coming and so it calls return to
indicate to you no more data will arrive
so observation and iteration are
actually deeply linked as we saw we just
turn one inside out and we get the other
and so this is what it would look like
to consume a web socket or a Dom event
that implemented this contract you could
just walk up to any of these data
sources and hand it a generator which is
just these three callbacks and then it
will just push streams of data at you
until it tells you it's done so we can
add sugar just like we added sugar for
iteration for that whole process of
calling symbol iterator and that while
loop and checking the done property just
like we
that sugar for that we can add sugar for
observation we could add like a for each
method for example to an observable that
return to promise when it resolved or as
I showed you guys earlier now that we
have a well-defined contract for
observation in JavaScript if we do we
can add a four on loop so consuming data
from a push stream can be done entirely
without callbacks so the hope would be
that if we introduce observable all the
push API is out there on the web can
implement this contract and on all of a
sudden we can just add language support
magically for all of these different
push data sources so if I learn to
consume an observable in ES 2016 at
least as the proposal stands I could do
something like this and this is just
going to keep printing out new signups
at Netflix I'm just going to keep going
so if an async function returns a
promise and a function star returns an
iterator we as language designers having
to have a question to answer what does
an async function star return right you
can't just go adding features to
languages and not describing what
happens when you put them together when
they interact well there's a couple of
different opinions about this and
there's actually a couple different ways
the committee could go but I'm here to
tell you today to tell you about one
particular option so if we look at this
table
we've got synchronous functions which
return a value we have synchronous
generators which return multiple values
right you can pull multiple values out
of but we also have asynchronous
functions which return a promise and a
promise pushes you one value right you
give it a callback and it pushes you a
value in that callback but what goes
here well if a function star returns
multiple values and an async function
pushes one value maybe an async function
star pushes multiple values and what
type pushes us multiple values
unobservable so we can envision in the
next version of JavaScript an async
function star which pushes you which
actually returns you an observable so
you could build a asynchronous generator
function which consumes data stalk data
for example and then translates it and
producer
do stock data so I want to now instead
of do you think just getting the next
price spike from a WebSocket I want to
get all the price spikes from a
WebSocket I'm actually going to use the
four on loop and I'm going to use yield
inside of a sync function star and this
whole thing is going to produce an
observable that pushes me all the price
specs all the the stock differences when
one stock comes on and another stock
comes along and that price difference is
over a certain threshold it's just going
to push it on through me through to me
and if I wanted to consume this I could
just use four on inside of an async
function and printer the console so what
does that mean it means symmetrical
support for functions that return
multiple values whether they're push or
they're pull you guys can stop worrying
about the machinery and the callbacks
and just focus on your code so this
particular proposal I just want to call
out is that the strawman phase it is the
earliest stage of the process and so
we're definitely going to be thinking
about this more and this may not make it
through as a final feature so I just
want to make that clear it's very early
in the future stages we're looking for
feedback on this right so we want to
hear from you about whether this works
for you and solves your problems so
thanks very much everybody
here's some resources for you and that's
the end of my talk